[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today so
so I have been listening to the show and
as well as Dr John deloney's show for
years but my husband and I have been
living paycheck to paycheck and using
credit cards to fill in gaps
um fast forward to today I'm pregnant
with baby number two to do at the
beginning of November congratulations
thank you
um and I'm four months into uh intensive
EMDR therapy
um just surrounding my childhood trauma
um and it feels like a fog has been
lifted and I'm seeing our situation more
clearly and now I'm just terrified and
don't know the right right way out of uh
the mess that we've created financially
can I just tell you that that's uh EMDR
is tough and I that's a courageous move
on your part I'm really proud of you
like for real and you're pregnant now
you've been you've been going through
that for the last few months
yeah yeah that will have
that will have dividends on your child's
nervous system that's growing inside of
you like what you've done is is
literally changing your family tree I'm
so proud of you it's amazing thank you
oh thank you and so so I remember one
time uh I was doing some hard trauma
counseling and a few months later my
counselor asked me
um and you may have heard me talk about
this on my show she asked me like what
do you feel and I said I feel like my
marriage is great my kids are great my
job is awesome
I don't know how to say this but
objectively if I was just to go down the
list
I would I would tell you I feel
depressed I feel like I'm running low
and she smiled real big and said this is
you for the first time
since you can remember that you're not
in fight or flight and she's smiling
goes this is what normal feels like and
you're gonna have to practice living
like this without being amped up and
fighting and running all the time and I
want to tell you it's been the best
living like falling asleep at night
because it's because I'm tired right
those kind of moments and so I tell you
all that to tell you as you begin to
heal
reality sets in right and for me that
reality was after 15 years of running
and screaming and fighting everybody and
running and trying to achieve everything
I got a good marriage I got a good job I
got a good life but also in your case
that could like the smoke can clear the
fog lifted as you said and you could
realize Whoa We owe a lot of money and
we are living paycheck to paycheck and
we're making some daily and weekly and
monthly choices that have to be
different or maybe my marriage isn't
what I want it to be or what I thought
it would be and so I think now you're in
a place where your body is telling you
okay now we have some real things to be
scared of in the present right and with
trauma like your body's responding in
the present to things that happened in
the past well now we've got some real
things in the present and so now I want
you to do this I want you to be really
curious about what your body's trying to
get your attention for and I hope you
hear my voice on purpose like huh what
are you trying to tell me so as you say
I'm scared tell me what you're scared of
what's your body trying to get your
attention about
um we just we don't have anything in
savings and we have
about thirty three thousand dollars and
um you know credit cards and we have a
truck and then we also have a mortgage
on top of that what do I do for a living
so I work for city government and my
husband's a carpenter okay how much you
guys make
um we he is unemployed for portions of
the year so
um we've been making about a hundred
thousand a year why does he choose to be
unemployed for parts of the year
um you know
I don't know so if I was a Gambling Man
and I'm terrible at gambling so I don't
really ever do it but if I was a
Gambling Man I would suggest to you that
a big alarm system that's going off in
your body is you are Tethered to
somebody that you don't feel safe with
and maybe not feel safe because he
doesn't hit you or doesn't scream or run
around on you but he does not providing
in a way that makes any sense to you and
you're a pregnant mother of one about to
be two you're working a full-time job
and he's sitting at home going I don't
know I don't know
is that is that is that ring a bell
yeah yeah
sounds like that's the place to start
yeah
that's what we find Emily is so often we
say on this show and it ends up being
really true is that our money problems
are just the symptom of other things
going on and so
um so I think yeah you addressing that
have you have you addressed concerns
with him in a very clear way that
your thoughts or are you just kind of
now coming to this reality as you're
calling us
um yeah we've talked about it and he
agrees with it and
he understands the Dave Ramsey plan and
wants to go along with it but then when
it comes to actually like making a
budget and sticking to it that's where
you know I get left alone well
there's a step beneath the Dave Ramsey
plan that he's not buying into and that
is I'm going to work to provide for my
family and take care of my family yeah
he's not honoring his wife and he's not
honoring his two kids
because he takes off half the year
and I I was just in Texas
um this past a couple days ago for a
speaking event and I went to visit my
friend who works maintenance at a
university and he's one of the greatest
guys in the world his name is Gustavo
and I went to visit him after move-in
day it's a thousand degrees in Texas and
I went to visit him after move-in day
when the maintenance guys are up from 4
30 in the morning until 4 pm at night
and I knocked on his door I haven't seen
him in a decade and his wife said oh
he's working he's at UPS right now
that's a guy that's working to take care
of his family
right he went after a job that would
have buried all of us and then he went
to his other job that would have buried
all of us it was such a as you see I'm
saying like that's that's taking care of
your family your husband's not doing
that and then the Dave Ramsey stuff like
Rachel we talked about it yeah he just
um he's not that's he's not a person of
integrity at that point yeah so the
conversation Emily I would have with him
is not well we're not doing the Dave
Ramsey I can't breathe it's I I'm scared
I'm scared and it's that's to the point
when that isn't answered and a couple
can't look at each other and say okay
how are we going to do this journey
together and lock arms and figure out
Solutions which could be the Dave Ramsey
plan
but when you're not willing to do that
that's when the marital issues really
come to light and that's when I would
say what bring in a third party
right now therapy to get your marriage
in a healthy spot and then looking at
your finances but in the meantime EMily
doing what you can of yeah creating a
budget not going in the whole
financially is the Band-Aid to kind of
keep you afloat but the bigger picture
here I think is that marriage piece so
we'd encourage you to go forward I would
uh hang on the line Emily because Austin
will pick up and I want to give you guys
Financial Peace University if you guys
can sit down and go through a few of
these lessons together I think it may be
really helpful to start the conversation
this is the Ramsay show